We will now go through a
beautiful example, in which we
approach the same question
in a number of different ways
and see that by reasoning
based on the intuitive
properties of a
Poisson process, we
can arrive quickly
to the right answer.
The problem is as follows.
We have three lightbulbs,
and each light bulb
is being lit at time
zero, it starts working,
and the light bulb lasts
for a certain amount
of time, which is random.
So this light bulb lasts so
long, this one lasts so long,
this one lasts that long.
The lifetime of a light bulb,
the time until it burns out,
will be a random
variable, and we
make the following assumptions.
The lifetimes of the
three light bulbs,
which we denote by
X, Y, and Z, will
be independent random
variables, each of which
is an exponential random
variable with the parameter
lambda.
We're interested in the
question of calculating
the expected time until
a light bulb burns out
for the first time.
So in this picture, the light
bulb that burned out first
is the second light
bulb, and this quantity
is the time until
the first burnout.
How do we calculate
this quantity?
The time until a first
light bulb burns out
is the minimum of the times
at which each one of them
burns out.
So we're interested
in the expected
value of this quantity.
It's a random variable,
which is a function of three
random variables.
How do we calculate
the expected value
of a function of
random variables?
We can use the
expected value rule.
Let us take the
function of interest,
which is the minimum
of three numbers.
Then we need to multiply by
the joint PDF or these three
random variables
X, Y and Z. Now,
because these three random
variables are independent,
the joint PDF is the product
of their individual PDFs,
which are all exponential.
And so we obtain this
expression for the joint PDF.
And we need to integrate this
over all x's, y's, and z's.
So it's going to
be an integral that
goes for each one of the three
variables from 0 to infinity.
And here we have dx, dy, dz.
So this is one approach
that can give us
the answer if you're able
to manipulate and keep
track of everything that happens
in this three-dimensional
integral.
But this is too tedious and
this is not a good way to go.
Let us try to think
of an alternative way.
Can we figure out
the distribution
of this random variable?
It's a function of three random
variables, so in some sense,
it's a derived
distribution problem,
so we can try to calculate
the cumulative distribution
function of the
minimum of the three.
So for the cumulative, we would
be looking at the probability
that the minimum of these three
random variables is less than
or equal to a certain number.
It turns out that
the calculations
are a little faster if we
look at the probability
that this is larger than or
equal to a certain number.
What is this event?
The minimum is larger
than or equal to t,
if, and only if,
all three of them
are larger than or equal to t.
So the probability of this event
is the same as the probability
that X is larger
than or equal to t,
Y larger than or equal to t,
and Z larger than or equal to t.
But now X, Y, and
Z are independent,
so we need to multiply
the probability that X
is larger than or
equal to t, which
for an exponential
random variable
is e to the minus lambda
t, then the probability
of the second event which is
again e to the minus lambda t,
and, finally, the probability
of the third event, which
is, again, e to
the minus lambda t,
which is e to the
minus 3 lambda t.
Now, we look at this
expression for the probability
that the random variable
is larger than or equal
to t and recognize that this
is the expression that we have
when we have an exponential
random variable with parameter
equal to 3 lambda.
If you want to do it formally,
subtract this quantity from 1
to find the CDF,
take the derivative,
and you will find
an exponential PDF.
So the conclusion is
that this random variable
is exponential with
parameter 3 lambda.
And since it's an exponential
with parameter 3 lambda,
then we know what the
expected value is.
It is going to be
1 over 3 lambda.
And this is the
answer to the question
that we were interested in.
Now, the fact that this is an
exponential random variable,
but with a different parameter,
is a pretty clean fact,
and so it should have
a good explanation.
Let us now try to think about a
good explanation for this fact.
Whenever we deal with an
exponential random variable,
one way of thinking
about it is that
this exponential random variable
is the first time in a Poisson
process.
So imagine that there's
a Poisson process that
runs forever, and X is
the first arrival time.
For this light bulb, we
can think the same way,
and since X and Y are
assumed to be independent,
we can assume that here we
have an independent Poisson
process, independent
from the first one,
it has its own arrival times,
and Y is the first arrival
time in this Poisson process.
And finally, we have a third
independent Poisson process,
and the random variable
Z is the first arrival
time in that Poisson process.
So X, Y and Z are
interpreted as first arrivals
in three independent
Poisson processes.
Now, let us take these
three Poisson processes
and merge them.
If we merge these three
processes, what we obtain
is a merged process, which
is Poisson with parameter
equal to the sum of the rates
or parameters of each one
of the processes, so
it's a Poisson process
with parameter 3 lambda.
Now, how can we interpret the
random variable of interest,
the first burnout time, in
terms of the merged process?
So the merged process
has an arrival
whenever one of those three
processes has an arrival.
The first arrival in
the merged process
will happen the first time that
one of these three processes
is going to have an arrival.
Therefore, we can interpret
the random variable
of interest, the
first burnout time,
as the first arrival
time in a merged process.
But now the merged process
is Poisson with parameter 3
lambda, therefore,
this random variable
is going to be an exponential
random variable with parameter
3 lambda.
And from this, we also
obtain the expected value
of that random variable.
The beauty of this last approach
for coming up with the answer
by reasoning in terms of
merged Poisson processes
is that we didn't have to do
any calculations at all, just
use the intuitive understanding
of Poisson processes
and, especially,
the interpretation
of an exponential random
variable as the first arrival
time in a Poisson process.
Let us now try to solve a
somewhat harder problem.
Let us try to calculate
the expected time
until all the light
bulbs burn out.
So one light bulb will burn out,
then another one will burn out,
and, finally, the third
one will burn out.
We want to find the expected
time until this happens.
Once more, we will be thinking
of these burnout times
as the first arrival times
in Poisson processes.
The total time until
the third burnout
can be split into
different periods.
There's a time until one
light bulb burns out.
And the expected
value of this period
here is going to
be 1 over 3 lambda.
What happens at this time?
The second light bulb has burned
out, so we can forget about it,
take it out of the picture.
We have two lightbulbs.
Let us look at the
time it will take
until one of these two
light bulbs burns out.
So we're interested in
this period of time.
Now, the Poisson process
starts fresh at this time.
After this time,
whatever happens
is just an ordinary
Poisson process
as if it were
starting at this time.
So this is going to be an
exponential random variable
starting from this time.
And this is going to be another
exponential random variable.
So the time until the next light
bulb burns out in this case
is going to be
the minimum of two
exponential random variables.
We can think again about
merging these two Poisson
processes to obtain a Poisson
process with total rate 2
lambda, and the time until
one of these two turns out
is going to be the first arrival
time in that merged process.
And so the expected time
until the first arrival
of the merged process is
going to be 1 over 2 lambda.
And finally, once this
burnout has happened,
we can forget about
this light bulb.
We're left just with one light
bulb, and starting from here,
we wait until that
light bulb burns out.
Once more, because of the fresh
start property of the Poisson
process, starting from
here until it burns out
is going to be a
random variable, which
is an exponential
random variable.
And in this case, an exponential
random variable with rate
just lambda.
And by adding these
three quantities,
we get the expected time until
all three have burned out.
This is a problem
that would have
been quite hard to solve
in a more analytical way.
We're dealing with a random
variable, which is now
the maximum of X, Y, and
Z. And the distribution
of this random variable is
not so simple to write down.
So that would not be
a very good approach
for going about this problem.
But we managed to find
the expected value
of this random variable
without having to write down
its distribution, by
breaking this random variable
into a sum of three particular
random variables, each of which
had a nice intuitive
interpretation.
And that was the key to the
solution of this problem.